Russia has confirmed a new prime
minister after the lower house of
parliament approved Vladimir Putin's
choice for the job and the president
formally appointed him Misha Misha stone
was head of the country's federal tax
service he was put forward as Putin's
choice for prime minister after Dmitri
Medvedev and his entire government
resigned on Wednesday in a State of the
Nation Address President Putin had
called for political reform giving more
power to the Parliament there's
speculation that Putin will take on a
new role when his current presidential
term ends in 2024 and DWS Emily Sherwin
is standing by for us in Moscow with
more hi Emily so as we saw the miss
Justin has been confirmed as a prime
minister but this was largely expected
wasn't it well absolutely Putin had kind
of suggested him as a candidate
yesterday the Duma had to approve that
suggestion today and that approval is
essentially a mere formality today miss
Justin's candidacy or passed with a huge
majority in fact no one voted against
him there were some abstentions it's
interesting now however to see what the
cabinet will be that masseuse tone will
propose he said that he would do that in
the coming days he'll present javadi Mir
Putin a list of the potential ministers
who might take on roles in the
government these are huge changes and we
took to the streets of Moscow to find
out what people think of all these
changes in government and also of the
changes proposed by Vladimir Putin let's
take a look no yeah I think it was time
for Medvedev to retire the political
system was stagnant and people want
something new now new decisions some
kind of renewal I think President Putin
made the right decision when he shook
everything up I mean yeah I saw fullness
- I don't know but I trust Putin to make
the right decisions good on him
I doubt anything will change maybe in
more civilized countries or States when
this kind of thing happens people do
expect change and for things to get
better but not here alright Emily so
some mixed voices on the streets there
can you tell us more about who the new
Prime Minister is and why he was
selected by Vladimir Putin for this job
well me human true steam has been in
government service for many many years
and he's been the head of the federal
tax service here in Russia since 2010
apparently he has the reputation of a
good manager of an efficient civil
servant a bureaucrat more than a
politician and someone to get the job
done now Putin yesterday announced huge
economic and social reforms along with
the constitutional reforms that he
announced so of what it comes to
internal policy perhaps he just wants
someone who will get the job done and he
knew Steen is a political unknown so no
one will think that he could be a
potential successor to Putin he's not a
political threat in that way he is
however someone known to modernize
things and to digitalize things as well
and he said itself these are big changes
underway in Russia you know political
shake-up and the government also
constitutional changes what is behind
all of this
well mr. shusun became prime minister
because Medvedev resigned yesterday
following Vladimir Putin speech to the
nation where he announced sweeping
constitutional changes including changes
that would strengthen the Parliament
both houses of the Parliament and weaken
the role of the president he also
announced proposed rather changes that
could strengthen the role of the
regional governors around Russia so kind
of decentralized things in Russia a bit
people will have to vote apparently on
these changes in some way Vladimir Putin
and all of these changes that we're
seeing are just are satisfying
a desire amongst Russian people for
change there was a real sense of
stagnation here in Russia up until
yesterday essentially but the main goal
observers say is that Putin is paving
the way for his own political future
Putin's term a current term as president
ends in 2024 he can't run again so
perhaps this is him kind of potentially
creating a new job for himself within a
new political system in the future all
right our correspondent Emily Sherwin in
Moscow thank you